MEDIA BUZZ BREAKS IT DOWN AT 11
A.M. EASTERN TOMORROW.
>> AS WE PREPARE TO HONOR THOSE
WHO MADE THE ULTIMATE SACRIFICE.
MEMORIAL DAY WILL LOOK DIFFERENT
THIS YEAR AS MANY STAY HOME AND
PRACTICE SOCIAL DISTANCING.
JOINING US TO TALK ABOUT THIS IS
VETERANS AFFAIR, ROBERT WILKE,
FOR JOINING US.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
BEFORE WE TALK ABOUT HOW WE
COMMEMORATE MEMORIAL DAY.
I’D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT SOMETHING
THAT HAPPENED IN THE LAST 24
HOURS.
IN A BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN YOUR
DEPARTMENT AND SENATE MINORITY
LEADER CHUCK SCHUMER, IT CAME TO
LIGHT THAT APPROXIMATELY 1300
VETERANS HAVE BEEN TREATED WITH
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
AND I’D LIKE TO PUT UP A
STATEMENT THAT SENATOR SCHUMER
GAVE IN RESPONSE TO THIS.
HE SAID, QUOTE, WE NEED TO KNOW
WHAT THE BASIS WAS FOR USING
THIS DRUG AGAINST THE CONSENSUS
OF SCIENCE, WHICH CALLED INTO
QUESTION ITS EFFECTIVENESS IN
TREATING COVID-19.
WE ALSO NEED TO KNOW WHO IS
AUTHORIZING THESE NEW TRIALS,
WHAT FACILITIES ARE
PARTICIPATING AND WHAT FAMILIES
ARE BEING TOLD.
SECRETARY, I’D LIKE TO GIVE YOU
AN OPPORTUNITY HERE TO RESPOND
THERE.
THE FIRST QUESTION, WHO DID
AUTHORIZE THESE NEW TRIALS?
AND SHOULD THERE BE CONCERN?
>> LET ME TAKE A STEP BACK WITH
THE SENATE DEMOCRATIC LEADER.
I THINK HE’S TRYING TO DIVERT
ATTENTION.
HE KNOWS BETTER THAN ANYONE THAT
WE USE THIS DRUG ON A DAILY
BASIS, 42,000 DOSES A DAY.
WE USE THE DRUG IN COORDINATION
WITH GUIDANCE THAT WE RECEIVED
FROM F.D.A.
AND SENATOR SCHUMER VOTED FOR
THE RIGHT TO TRY ACT, WHICH IS
UNDERLYING OUR EFFORTS WHEN IT
COMES TO DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO SAVE LIFE AND PROLONG LIFE.
WE DO THIS, WE’VE USED THIS DRUG
IN CONJUNCTION, NOT ONLY WITH
THE F.D.A., BUT OUR DOCTORS AND
IN CONJUNCTION WITH FAMILIES AND
VETERANS.
WE’RE DOING EVERYTHING THAT WE
CAN TO TRY TO PRESERVE LIFE AND
WE FOLLOW GUIDELINES.
THE OTHER THING I WOULD ALSO
NOTE, IS THAT ON THE DAY I WAS
ON FOX A FEW WEEKS AGO, SENATOR
SCHUMER’S OWN GOVERNOR, THE
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK, WAS ASKING
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES FOR TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOSES.
AND I ALSO WANT TO NOTE FOR
SENATOR SCHUMER HE IS
CONVENIENTLY SKIPPING A LOT OF
FACTS IN THIS ARGUMENT AT THE
SAME TIME THAT HE HAS BEEN
SILENT IN SEVEN LANGUAGES ABOUT
THE THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
DEATHS THAT HAVE OCCURRED IN HIS
OWN BACK YARD BECAUSE OF
MISMANAGEMENT OF NURSING HOMES.
SO, I WANT TO PUT THIS IN THE
CONTEXT OF SOMEONE TRYING TO
DEFLECT ATTENTION FROM WHAT IS
GOING ON IN ONE’S OWN BACK YARD.
>> DO YOU HAVE AN UPDATE ON THE
1300 JUST BIG PICTURE, HOW
THINGS HAVE GONE?
>> WELL, WE’VE USED THIS DRUG,
NORMALLY WE’VE USED IT AS A LAST
EFFORT TO KEEP PEOPLE ALIVE.
WHAT THOSE STUDIES DID NOT
INVESTIGATE WERE THE UNDERLYING
MEDICAL CONDITIONS THAT THESE
VETERANS WERE FACING.
IN THE ORIGINAL REPORT WE USED
THIS IN THE LAST HOURS OF A
VETERAN’S LIFE IN THE HOPES THAT
IT COULD PROLONG THAT LIFE AND
AGAIN, IF YOU’VE BEEN IN THE
MILITARY OR YOU’VE BEEN IN VA
SINCE 1955, WE’VE ALL USED IT.
WE KNOW ITS SIDE EFFECTS AND AS
WITH ANY DRUG, EVEN ASPIRIN,
THERE WILL BE SOMEONE WHO HAS A
NEGATIVE REACTION TO THAT DRUG.
BUT WE’RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK UNDER F.D.A. GUIDELINES.
THAT’S THE SCIENCE.
AND I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT DR.
FAUCI HIMSELF, SOMEONE I SIT
WITH IN THE NATIONAL CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE, IS CONDUCTING THE
SAME KINDS OF TRIALS IN HIS
INSTITUTE THAT WE ARE.
>> OKAY.
AND JUST BEFORE WE RUN OUT OF
TIME, I REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE TALK ABOUT THIS WEEKEND AND
THE IMPORTANCE OF MEMORIAL DAY
AND IT’S LOOKING SO DIFFERENT
THIS WEEKEND.
>> SURE.
>> CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHAT’S BEING
DONE?
>> WELL, WE’VE NEVER CLOSED OUR
CEMETERIES, ALICIA, ALL 142 ARE
OPEN.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS THAT WE
HAVEN’T ALLOWED LARGE GROUPS OF
PEOPLE COME CELEBRATE.
WE ISSUED A JOINT STATEMENT WITH
OUR FRIENDS IN THE BOY SCOUTS
WHO ARE USUALLY OUT THERE
PLANTING FLAGS, THEY WILL BE
TIED INTO OUR VETERANS LEGACY
PROJECT, WHICH ALL OF OUR
VETERANS IN OUR DEVELOPMENT TRIS
HAVE A BIOGRAPHY ON OUR WEBSITE.
AT 3:00 ON MEMORIAL DAY, THEY
WILL ALL BE IN THEIR UNIFORMS,
STANDING AT ATTENTION, LISTENING
TO A BUGLER BLOW TAPSMENT WE’LL
HAVE THE FLAGS OUT, BUT IT WILL
BE OUR PEOPLE PUTTING THEM DOWN
AND WE ASK PEOPLE TO REMEMBER
THAT THE AMERICAN WARRIOR IS A
UNIQUE PERSON IN HISTORY.
THE ONLY WARRIOR IN HISTORY
WHO’S OFFERED A HELPING HAND NOT
ONLY TO THE PEOPLE HE’S BOUND TO
SERVE, BUT TO THE ENEMIES THAT
HE FOUGHT AND I THINK THAT’S A
LEGACY THAT ALL AMERICANS CAN BE
PROUD OF.
>> IT’S SO EASY TO FORGET THE
REAL REASON FOR THE DAY.
SO MANY FOLKS GET CAUGHT UP IN
THEIR BARBECUES AND ENJOYING THE
SUNSHINE AND ALL OF THAT, BUT IS
REALLY IS IMPORTANT, IT’S A
SOLEMN DAYS, AN IMPORTANT DAY.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT ON MONDAY,
YOU, SECRETARY, WILL PRESIDE
OVER THE WREATH LAYING AT
QUANTICO IN VIRGINIA, AND WE